John's with us and Houston Texas hi John
how are you hello mr. Ramsey thank you
so much for taking my call
sure how can I help well last year I
lost my job that I was with for 15 years
and over the corium entually depressed
and I have accumulated over $90,000 in
credit card debt sir and I have it not a
judgment I have a credit card company
that has filed a lawsuit in my head II
and you know I've talked to a couple of
attorneys but they're wanting about
$4,000 just thinking of the case and
information and I just don't have that
type of cash to do anything and you know
I have a house even though I've been
unemployed been looking for work I have
a house that I have with my dad my dad
collect Social Security I'm living with
him and I just really don't know how to
pull myself out of the bad choices that
I made using my credit cards how old are
you
41 and what kind of a job did you have I
was a manager for a retail store manager
okay all right and why have you been
unable to find work because you're
depressed
been out looking and just yes I've been
you know emotionally and mentally
depressed mm-hmm well it's hard to be
energetic and be your best self when
you're suffering from depression and so
it makes the energy level for the job
search low and then it makes the
interview underperform both is that true
yes yeah and and yet the very thing that
solves all of this is an income you know
are you doing are you doing anything to
earn any kind of money
just you know working online songs you
know a couple of hundred dollars a month
pretty well living off your dad's social
security then yes sir okay have you seen
a counselor no I have not
are you a member of a church yes I am
okay the interesting thing is is that
it's a chicken and egg problem I'm not a
mental health professional okay I'm just
a guy I have the 30 years of experience
of coaching people in the financial
world and oftentimes I run into folks
that are struggling from depression and
the depression is aggravated by the
financial problems which then is which
then aggravates the depression are the
depressions aggravated by the financial
problems which then aggravates the the
job situation the income situation and
that makes that worse and so it's kind
of a spiral downward like the job gets
worse so the depression gets worse so
the financial gets worse so the job gets
worse so the financial gets worse of the
diversion you see what I'm saying and so
we have to stop we have to do something
to drop a bomb in the middle of that
spiral and start going the other
direction okay
so first things first your worst case
scenario with the credit card debt is
that you would file bankruptcy your next
worst case scenario with the credit card
debt is that they would sue you and
actually win the good news is you live
in Texas you have homestead laws there
they cannot put a lien on your personal
residence as a result of consumer debt
and a lawsuit they also cannot garnish
your wages in Texas so the bottom line
is they're going to get nothing they're
a dog running around the bottom of the
tree barking and you're safely up in the
branches okay so what about like you
ain't gone it's the wages out of my best
account you have to check an attorney in
Texas but you don't have any money in
your bank account
I have like $3,000 chives that's it okay
and so it's not you know they're not
it's not like there's they're more bark
than bite because you're in Texas
there's not a lot they can do okay you
can check an attorney I'm not one but
that that's going to what you're going
to find you can actually do a little
google search and start to find out what
they're able to do in Texas and it's
going to be nothing that doesn't fix
your problem though let's pretend the
debt went away completely we still have
a guy who's struggling with depression
who doesn't have a job which means we
got another financial problem tomorrow
right if we waved a wand and all your
debt went away completely instantly
you've still got a you still got any
issue so what I'm going to tell you to
do is let's start to work on the other
side of it let's take the debt problem
slide it over here to the left just out
of emotional range and not wring our
hands over it because they can't do a
lot about it and because you can't do a
lot about it for just a minute let's set
it over to the side and let's work on
John call your pastor and tell him you
desperately need to have a cup of coffee
with him this week tell him what's going
on sit down with someone in your church
and get some men around you that will
care about you and will walk with you
through this process number two will you
do that if I ask you to do it yes you
hope depression is solved by taking
action activity number two start an
exercise regime today tomorrow morning I
want you to walk two miles or go to the
Y and lift weights I don't care
start doing something where your heart
rate goes up because it releases
adrenaline into your bloodstream
proteins endorphins into your
bloodstream which is not the salvation
for a depression but it does help and
when you just sit around and worry all
day it makes everything worse
chemically okay you follow me number two
exercise regime will you do that well
number three do you have a car wonderful
I want you to start delivering Pete
is immediately or driving uber either
one you choose and there it's not your
end it's not they gonna do anything
except cause you to be doing something
and when you start doing something and a
little bit of money comes in it starts
to feel better and when it starts to
feel better you're more marketable when
you go on a real interview for a real
job then we get your real job kicked
back in and you're feeling better you
may be seeing a counselor because you're
making a little money to pay one and
getting some help with this depression
not just a farm boy like me helping you
okay
but then after you're doing all of that
you start to make a little money we'll
go back and attack these credit card
debts and settle them for pennies on the
dollar you can get them out of your life
with the credit card that's not the
problem here it's the symptom and we
have to track the actual problem first
hang on I'm gonna send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
to help you on that job hunt